hey guys it is the 7th of July my name
is just and you are watching games
button just like last year destiny is
offering moments of triumph for each
year to content where you can go and
complete challenges for rewards before
the release of its next expansion rise
of all the tasks cover everything from
completing the exotic sword quest to
killing Oryx in the hard version of the
Kings full rate if you're not these off
you'll be rewarded with various rewards
like emblems and shaders the moments of
triumph are available to earn until sep
tember 21 riser pine right if you can to
get stuck in you can visit the
postmaster to check on your progress and
find out what you have left to do Bungie
also announced that one hundred percent
of the profits made from their bunchy
store in 2016 will go to the bungee
foundation charity which helps children
in need so if you want to pick yourself
up a shirt featuring your destiny class
of choice now is a good time following
last night's announcement that evolve is
getting a free version the game is now
available on scene if you already own
the game you should see an update to the
stage 2 edition download automatically
for the rest of you you can visit its
store page on steam to pick the game up
for free technically the stage 2 edition
is listed as a beta but it consists of
the full game yep total rock have taken
a game that was infamous for costing you
a [ __ ] ton of money and made it totally
free there isn't even anything in game
you can spend money on at the current
time even if you wanted to for those who
did buy the game you'll get immediate
access to all content you earned
previously and founder status whatever
that means Turtle Rock say they're
adding more customization options
improving progression reducing load time
fixing bugs and tweaking the map and you
I the developer at large what they
called the deal please shitstorm and
said that it washed away piece of
enthusiasm dragging us further and
further from that first magical pick up
and play
experience that hoping the Free Edition
will bring the magic back finally the
new GTA online update is utter madness
and keeps what I mean by that becoming
stumps update for GTA online is
launching on jun 12 as will let you
engage in stunt races these involve you
racing through loops and tubes speeding
off grants and driving through massive
rings of fire on courses way above the
ground in the Los Santos skyline roster
have explained the jump gaps terrain and
obstacles in each race are tailored to
match the attributes of specific vehicle
classes including new super cars sports
cars & hué motorbikes and of course
racing livery cloud vehicles deserve
appropriately charted and dressed
drivers sporting new motocross gear
racing suit helmet and a host of other
additions aside from this update rock
star hoez dead players can expect more
weekly events and rewards for
participating in them we saw ahead to
game slot where we've got news on
literally everything you need to know
about the game at the moments Pokemon go
and find fantasy 15 come back tomorrow
for my top 5 stories of the entire week
I hope to see them